a música como ferramenta de conexão
música pra quebrar paradigmas como é que
a música surge nas nossas vidas
na minha vida eu uma tenra idade ea mãe
professora de educação física levava lá
pra casa umas coisas para coreografar
umas danças umas roupas que achava tudo
bacana aquilo e eu ficava interessante
esse ficado interessado naquilo envia-la
é criando com aquela outra amiga dela a
professora aquele monte de coisa ela
falava filho essas fitas é igual ney
matogrosso olha que bacana ela fazia
tudo girava e eu ficava encantado e meu
pai ele ele gostaria ele sonhava ser um
baterista né ele tocava numa banda mas
que não deu muito certo não foi pra
frente e minha mãe de nome de um mina e
meu pai do meu dárcio ainda bem que eles
não são esse casal que junta nomes senão
seria um dominou as hildelene não seria
um composto químico mas não seria
fernando e aí com esse espírito dentro
de casa já de de música de oportunidade
de vir de vivências eles me levavam
sempre a igreja no final de semana e lá
tinha uma capela onde a gente podia
ficar livre para mexer no piano na
bateria e guitarra no baixo e mesmo sem
saber tocar aquilo era uma diversão
descobrir os sons aquilo era uma coisa
que me instigava eu gostava muito disso
gostava de fazer vozes logo à tarde você
que está me ouvindo
gostava de ficar inventando coisinha
fazer personagens daquela voz igual do
desenho tinha um acampamento eu gostava
de participar daquela coisa do teatro
eu gostava de ali criar os personagens
enfim isso tudo me encantava poder rimar
amor como humor e descobrir que atrás
disso ainda viu metáforas uma coisa
fabulosa sempre sonhei em si
músico e o sonho de qualquer músico é
justamente a alcançar aquela gravadora a
gravadora vai te dar o status que você
precisa vai te dar força que você
precisa vai divulgar sua música tudo
quanto é lugar vai tocar no rádio vai
tocar na televisão só que não não é nada
disso
naquela naquela busca é por um envolvido
com pessoas assim comecei a freqüentar
saraus e o sarau é aquela oportunidade
de você compartilhar com outras pessoas
suas vivências coisas que você acredita
coisas que você não acredita coisas que
você sonha é ou às vezes fica em
silêncio e acompanhar aquilo tudo
esse espírito sarau euro ele tinha um
espírito colaborativo
o sarau sempre terminava uma catarse
coletiva que era sempre inusitado e isso
era muito bacana eu falei porque a gente
não leva isso em cima do palco
esse espírito de misturar as coisas
todas de ser plural mas aquilo estava só
na cabeça enfim eu queria na verdade é
buscando assim o sonho de música então
não conseguia não tinha tempo para
organizar essa coisa que ali vivência
nacional eu tinha eu tinha uma outra
banda que era um trio de música
brasileira e foi chamado por uma
gravadora
a gravadora convidou a gente não vem
cães vão gravar essas músicas são
fabulosas que bacana e eu nem sei se é
isso mesmo tal beleza
a gente foi assinar todos os documentos
que precisava entrou na gravadora
primeiro mês nada
segundo mês nada terceiro mês nada
quarta um ano nada
ele escuta a gente a não ser começar a
gravar a gente começou a gravar no
estúdio lá na oitava música o dono da
gravadora bem falou para tudo é para
refazer tudo inversão de forró escarro
mas não faz sentido a nossa música não
tem nada a ver com isso ela não
representa mas é pra fazer forró escape
mas o foco está na mesma forma gaveta um
fomos ingá vetados durante os dois anos
a gente não podia tocar é é lançar
nenhum projeto novo e ainda momento já
internet não
acontecia ela estava nos seus primórdios
né é as comunidades de orkut ainda não
estava nem no no esboço
então aquele momento e falei caramba
cara a gente ficou preso num
engavetamento e eu achando que esse
sonho tal não sei o quê conclusão a
banda acabou se desfez e meu pai
indignado com isso pegou todas as
músicas que eu tinha e jogou na rede
jogou na internet falei pai mas você fez
isso cara
todas as minhas músicas na internet
agora todo mundo vai saber minhas
músicas e falou não é isso não é um cara
engravatado atrás de uma mesa que vai
dizer se o seu trabalho é bom se você
tem talento é o público fazendo fila na
porta
são as pessoas ouvindo ali pra mim
receber aquele sinal o frio faz todo o
sentido eo meu irmão caçula que é um
sociólogo logo é o meu irmão mais velho
ele a música tem que ser gratuita
mas como assim gunam de gustavo mas
comecemos não tem que ser gratuito a
música livre mas mas como cara na
essência a música livre
quando a gente vai fazer uma
manifestação na rua reclamar a tarifa
falta do transporte
ali tem música e música têm ritmo em
pulsação música tem qualquer lugar é é e
pascual por exemplo faz música por
qualquer coisa um bule com um sapato ele
pega um pouquinho de estimação leva para
o palco e aperta a na hora certa um
pouquinho participar música a gente
consegue fazer qualquer coisa a grande
questão é o porquê
pra que eu estou fazendo música tem
gente que não sabe porque pra cá e acaba
se perdendo entre um comercial chiclete
a sua própria obra o cara não sabe
qualquer um qualquer qual o porquê pra
que fazer música um qual intuito o qual
espírito
a partir desse momento foi bom beleza
então a música gratuita eu vou ter que
dar nos um bocadinho nenhum não tem como
tirar o meu sustento não calma não é
isso
dizia meu irmão caçula mas
espiritualmente mais velho falou não é
um cara à música
ela tem que alcançar
as pessoas têm que alcançar sua obra uma
música que eu simplesmente não houve até
agora ela pra mim é silêncio ela não
existe isso é qualquer música enquanto o
seu novo a música silêncio
então quem diz que está protegendo a
música impedindo ela de ser veiculada
cometeu um grande equívoco porque música
que nem passarinho precisa doar pra
sobreviver para se propagar
é só com essa identidade reconhecendo o
peso o valor da música que a gente sim
poderia então trabalhar em cima disso
bom a gravadora não queria gente a banda
acabou meu pai falou que puxar música
tem que ser feito um ótimo vou levar
esse espírito aqui do sarau para cima do
palco e vamos trabalhar de uma maneira
plural né a as nossas nossos arranjos os
ritmos né as nossas cores
vamos levar tudo isso poesia teatro
circo música o que a gente puder porque
tudo dialoga uma coisa com a outra
no circo em teatro e tem música no
teatro tem música que tem circo e tem
poesia na poesia a poesia tem a sua
melodia tem a sua musicalidade
então tudo está interligado no tema e
por que separar as coisas
é tudo uma coisa só e com esse espírito
então a gente resolveu montar um grupo
chamado teatro mágico é um grupo que
realmente na primeira apresentação era
uma grande bagunça organizada eu
convidei umas 30 pessoas para participar
em sair com 15 pessoas num dia com 15 no
outro dia no terceiro já ninguém
lembrava do que iria acontecer mas
aconteceu
foi lindo a gente cantou tudo foi bacana
o pessoal entendeu do que se tratava e
as pessoas que estavam ali o público
reconheceu que as músicas sim deveria
então ser tratada de uma maneira é como
posso dizer colaborativa as músicas
passaram a se propagar ou só começou a
disseminar isso na rede é aqueles textos
de de msn que a pessoa tinha era sempre
uma fase em que o teatro mágico ou
alguma coisa no site
a gente sempre jogando jogando porque a
música
descobriu no público o nosso maior
parceiro o público
quando você toca é você vai faz um show
uma apresentação o que a gente percebia
que a pessoa que ficava ali na grade
divino chupar a acabar a apresentação é
até a barraquinha lá e quem fica na
barra na barra na barraca na barra que é
o seu odácio é meu pai
ele trabalha no melhor lugar que um pai
coruja poderia trabalhar na saída do
show do filho dele
aí o pessoal vai lá pega um cd vai pra
casa abrirá uma rede social espertos e
do computador amigos ou são isso pá isso
é crime
compartilhar música então agora é crime
o que até então era uma troca de
afetividade passou a ser crime
a gente usava disco de vinil a gente
tinha aquele momento de tirar o disco do
plástico colocar escolher a faixa essa é
essa
se essa atitude com o livro nessa essa
maneira de tratar esse namoro essa coisa
romântica se perdeu chegou cedeu o cd
você fazia algumas cópias você conseguia
fazer uma coletânea um outro cd enviar
alguém mas antes disso tinha fita
cassete que nunca teve uma fita cassete
escrito lentas e aí
poxa você tinha o disco você tinha fita
você tinha um cd e aí você passou a
baixar o mp3 não precisava mais em cd e
hoje em dia ninguém baixar nada se você
for uma música agora eu vou pegar o
celular ao escrever o nome da música ou
apertar o botão ea música vai tocar tudo
na nuvem tudo na nuvem
então o que é fantástico não é agente a
isso acabando com os artistas está
destruindo a nossa possibilidade de
sobreviver não detêm compreender que
isso mudou a as gerações se
transformaram a gente hoje passou a ter
voz público passou a ser protagonista
o público é que decide o que eu quero
ouvir o que não quer ouvir
se você vai ouvir olha onde você ouve
música da onde você consegue receber
música ou do rádio ou da tv daquele
programa que o pessoal vai pra cantar e
todo mundo fala que ele é bom ou não
em outro programa que as bandas têm
essas coisas e você é obrigado a
acreditar que a nossa cultura está
fadado aquelas coisas que aparecem em
programas de sábado e domingo à tarde
também é aquilo mas não pode ser só isso
o que é fundamental a gente compreender
que falta de democracia na nossa
comunicação não há políticas públicas
para trabalhar a música livre numa
políticas públicas para trabalhar a arte
nesse momento onde ela se amadurece
neste momento onde ela se transforma
onde o público passa então a ser essa
pessoa ativa esse parceiro do músico
esse parceiro do artista onde reproduzir
as coisas não é mais crime
muito pelo contrário é você criar uma
parceria junto com o seu público
você simplesmente nessa cadeia da música
que tenho o cara que faz a música
o cara quer arranjar a música o cara que
vai trabalhar isso dentro de um site o
cara que organizar isso de uma maneira
legal e o público a gente tirou os
atravessadores culturais
a gente tentou juntar o artista direto
com o público
esse espírito de fazer as coisas de uma
maneira comum onde tudo era uma coisa só
passou a ser uma referência até o vídeo
e um de um produtor famoso pau poxa o
teatro mágico é uma exceção essa coisa
de da música de graça é coisa que num
não funciona
eu respondi para ele e não nós não somos
uma exceção
nós temos uma possibilidade porque assim
como o teatro mas vários outros grupos
podem sim dessa relação com a sua obra
com o seu público e transformar essa
coisa que a gente acha esse status o
corpo que está colocado com esse
espírito
a gente descobriu que sim hoje o público
é o maior parceiro de qualquer artista
seja esse artista alguém está começando
alguém que já tava em alguma gravadora e
depois saiu porque teve que sair alguma
coisa mas enfim desça do palco dessa do
salto
conheça seu público converse com ele
saiba quem é quem efetivamente a gente
responde na rede a gente conversa
pessoalmente isso tira o artista
ele planeta dos artistas onde o cara vai
no show acaba o show ele entra num carro
e vai lá para o planeta dos artistas
lá ele encontra aquela lá aquele outro e
aquele outro lado aquele time e não fala
com ninguém é intocável é uma grande
besteira
essa e se esse esse lugar onde coloca o
artista né é uma grande besteira a gente
é trabalhador com qualquer outra pessoa
a gente tem tenta fazer uma música 10
por semana para ver se uma presta e às
vezes não não presta e às vezes quando
você acha que presta e lança aquele fã
mais racional e apaixonado não gostei
perdeu a essência mas então a gente tem
que compreender trabalhar com isso e
resolver as nossas as nossas diferenças
eu peguei resolveu então fazer uma
música como público em parceria com o
público estava no twitter eu falei quais
são as coisas que a gente perde a gente
nem se dá conta
então lembrei de anel aliança chinelo
chave da casa documento aquele recibo no
estacionamento e quais são os
sentimentos que a gente pede que a gente
não pode perder o público que você
escrever poxa carinho coragem perdão
e aí surge uma música que fala assim eu
vou tocar um trecho dela depois daquela
clama pela sua poesia que a senhora onde
vai o da tampa de caneta do recibo de
estacionamento
original isqueiro caderneta a camiseta
com aquele sinal não te fai toda a
paleta ground fui tudo nosso carnaval
onde vai no do abridor de lata dó
carteira de habilitação recado não dado
um centavo cajá ano todo guarda-chuva
para a fuga
o temporal próximo vai o achado bebeu
não se veja venho me leve a mal onde vai
tudo mais 6 carteira pipa marido nem
paulo onde vai rodar já dema recibo
receita eo nosso enredo inicial onde vai
guardar de acampamento
brasília acabou batendo de cacau
elástico de cabelo quando se defende de
contato
a nossa memória a nossa memória
eu esqueci o resto essencialmente é isso
fazer música uma parceria de nome
twitter acesse twitter us você acaba
esquecendo um pedaço da letra o que a
gente não pode esquecer essencialmente é
que é tudo uma coisa só
todo sujeito livre para conjugar o verbo
que quiser todo o verbo é livre para ser
direto ou indireto nenhum predicado será
prejudicado nem tão pouco a frase nem
atrasos e nem a vírgula e ponto final
afinal a magra matka da vida nos foi
entre pausas entre vírgulas estar entre
vírgulas pode ser a posto e eu aposto
oposto evocativa todos sendo apenas um
sujeito simples um sujeito e sua oração
sua pressa sua prece que enxergamos o
fato de termos acessórios para a nossa
oração separados ou adjuntos nominais ou
não façamos parte do contexto
sejamos todas as capas da edição
especial mas porém contudo entretanto
todavia não obstante raul eva sejamos
também a contra capa é porque será capa
e ser contra a capa é a beleza da
contradição é negar a si mesmo e negar a
si mesmo é muitas vezes encontrar se com
deus com o teu deus
senhoras e senhores nesse momento que
cada um se encontra aqui agora que um
possa se encontrar no outro e outro num
até porque tem horas que a gente se
pergunta porque é que não se junta tudo
numa coisa só